okie dokie MV Dexter is the opponent's
name and we get what Queens and Yaya I'm
playing this a little bit recently with
white without having without any
particular knowledge and it did shows I
really I really have problems quite
often I have much more experience with
the with the namazu Indian and ok how do
play how do you play this yet probably
taking it if oriya 45 he cannot take
before the long diagonal is a problem
wow what is this g5 you can allow g5
here it's it's it's hard to believe
Bishop c3d see six wins so okay does he
goes for that and I can take here Jake
c7 for starters yeah probably
yeah so it had netted me a pawn it
wasn't it wasn't him gallic blundering
the house but it's still nice of course
yeah I guess 94 cannot be really bad
okay so here thought night at five
actually but oks bishop is pretty strong
so it's not not a not a very clear-cut
situation actually
that's not so clear surprisingly
wonder if I missed something there so it
seems very likely really that I had some
opportunity that I that I didn't take
him I'm trying to go for 97 him
using the active night yeah Wow no sure
those direct threats there with Queenie
eight now ok so if I go a three now
where are you going a five is also
hanging
okay so taking this I guess Queen c7 is
quite serious also Quincy 7 now with the
double attack answer I'm kind of
inconvenient right 197 okay let's let's
play that threatens quite a bit si tu
hangs and that's made check made next
Muslim black resigns hmm laughs but it
was it was surprising that he he allowed
d5 maybe he has no other move yet that's
possible it did it felt really strange
this thing but it wasn't as bad as I
thought to be honest I hear can 94 is
not a good idea really the comp wants to
go like 92 or okay one that's probably
guru ki one is a very very computer ish
idea but 92 is interesting and for
recapturing with the night it's not a
bad idea at all here it's not I mean
they can do that but I wasn't really
sure about this yeah the engine is still
basically giving me a clear you know one
idea that I did not really see us I saw
that if he goes g6 my night is hanging
so I went I wanted to go here but I can
I have night c4 next this is very
important it keeps my it coordinates the
whole position and keeps pressure on a 5
and so on that's really nice ok and
after this d 6 it is tricky check yeah
it's probably lost them I don't
I don't see how we defense there it's
two parts they cannot take anywhere 27
now Windsor yeah he has no movie if he
goes here I give him a justice check
here and I'm threatening this and this
and both both at the same time is too
much winning the pc on c2 yeah that was
a was a quite nice one thanks for
watching